What you want to do is find a hundred percent of them. Right now,
people estimate we found about 90% of that leaves,
10% of asteroids.
We don't know where they are and whether or not they're going to cross the
Earth's orbit with us there anytime soon.
So we want to keep watching the skies and finding these things.
Uh, and then, you know, you want 20 or 30 years notice,
so you can do something to keep it from hitting the
earth.
So, Peter, hello, Richard, how are you? Very well.
I'm going to start right out of the gate. Yes. Come in hot.
How do you feel about Armageddon? Is this,
the topic of today's podcast is sort of the topic of
today's pod.
Are you talking about Armageddon as in the biblical sense of Armageddon,
not the biblical sense of that place,
where the final battle between good and evil happens. Uh,
you could argue in some cases, Armageddon, no matter what it is,
is going to refer to some sort of end of the world scenario. In this case,
I am referring to the classic and I am doing air quotes. If you're listening,
uh, Armageddon, the movie, Michael Bay, Jerry Bruckheimer,
uh, Bruce Willis stars is the head of a plucky blue collar.
He lost me at Michael Bay. Yes. Uh, it is the scenario where,
and the reason applies to today's show is that there is an asteroid barreling
down on the earth. It will essentially wipe out everyone,
Billy Bob Thornton's essentially the NASA guy,
perfect Sydney and their scenarios. Yes, of course.
And their idea to deal with this existential threat is to send up a drilling
team, a deep drilling team,
the best deep drill drilling team to drill into an asteroid,
send up the worst. No, you wouldn't want it. I mean, it,
it made sense right out of the gate, go with the best. Um,
and of course there's a great love story with the young Ben Affleck and Liv
Tyler, and of course live Tyler's father Aerosmith, lead singer, Steven Tyler,
and the song that was part of, I don't want to close my eyes.
I don't want to CO's man,
I don't want to fall asleep cause I miss you, babe, ladies and gentlemen,
Richard Garner. So crooning aside, it was huge. It was a huge movie.
It was one of these massive blockbuster, you know, sort of disaster movies,
but it really put the scenario on the radar of a lot of people about, you know,
what would we do in that? So of course, what do you do here at the old? Uh,
what if headquarters, you asked those questions. What if we blew up an asteroid?
Cause I don't know the answer. Do you know the answer?
I've heard a little bit about it,
but I would like to explore it a little bit more.
Would you like to defer to somebody who might know the answer?
I think we have a pretty good guest who might be able to talk about this at
length. We happen to have, I think the perfect guest for probably any,
what if hypothetical, but this case in particular, the one, the only bill Nye,
the science guy, yes. We were able to get bill Nye, the science.
I love it when he joins us. Well, tell us more about, uh, Pete. Okay.
Bill Nye is a scientist engineer, comedian author, and inventor.
He's also a man with a mission to help foster a scientifically literate society
and to help people everywhere,
understand and appreciate the science that makes our world work.
Bill's classic show bill Nye,
the science guy was nominated for 23 Emmys and one
19 and it paved the way for a career in making science
accessible, fun and super cool.
And he's still doing exactly that with his sensationally entertaining and
informative podcast science rules with bill Nye.
Well, thanks so much for joining us.
We're super happy to have you on the show today. It's so good to be happy.
Well it's we all love to be had,
but before we get into the sort of the bigger whiff of what,
if we blew up an asteroid, uh,
we were talking off the top boat Armageddon and um, I'm assuming you've seen it.
And B I was thinking about, what is it like to watch a movie with bill Nye,
especially if there's science involved,
because I imagined he'd be pointing out what is sort of a stretch and what
isn't,
if you remember that 1998 classic deep drilling into an asteroid,
was that a even feasible?
And B what did you think of how they handled the science?
Well, here's the thing about it. You guys, you don't want to blow it up.
That's the surprising thing
because you probably get a shower of stuff that's on the same trajectory,
uh, as they say, and I'm, I only read about this.
I'm not involved in research,
but Bruce bets at the planetary society is deeply involved in this.
A lot of asteroids, aren't solid rocks. They're in the expression.
The charming expression in astronomy is the rubble piles.
They're just, um,
a loose collection of rocks held together by their mutual gravity.
And uh, so if you set off an explosion explosive near them,
you would just disperse them.
But their overall momentum wouldn't change that much. Like they blow apart,
but they'd still keep coming and they still keep coming at you.
And so it's a very, uh,
it's a very high risk scenario or way to go
about trying to deflect.
Because it's rain and rocks basically is what you're saying.
Like basically a bunch of smaller meteorites all over the place.
Which would be just as deadly. I'm guessing.
Well, maybe, and you know, maybe worse, you know, if, uh,
they land all over the place instead of one place, you know, as we say,
if you like to worry about things, asteroids are great.
Bill. They say NASA, they tell us that NASA is tracking some 20,000,
any owes a near earth objects at any one time. What does,
what does the process look like?
And you guys be proud, Canadian space agencies deeply involved in that,
you know, the, uh,
Canadian space agency has an instrument on almost every mission that ever flies.
That's not from Chinese, uh, space administration. So, um,
uh, what you want to do is find a hundred percent of them right now,
people estimate we found about 90% of, well,
that leaves 10% of asteroids.
We don't know where they are and whether or not they're going to cross the
Earth's orbit with us there anytime soon.
So we want to keep watching the skies and finding these
things. Uh, and then, you know, you want 20 or 30 years notice,
so you can do something,
send Bruce Willis or whatever you want to do something to, uh,
keep it from hitting the earth.
And then there's this whole other thing about mitigation where you get everybody
to leave Winnipeg. So if it lands there,
everybody you'll be okay, but this is a very,
these are extraordinary things because the earth is turning.
There is going through space and these objects are largely
rock, but many of them also have ice.
And then there's other objects that you don't, you can't see near them.
So their trajectory is pretty predictable,
but there are errors or unknowns on the order
of a few days, or let's say half a day.
So is it going to land in Winnipeg or Vancouver or Tokyo
is like, Whoa, you can't really be sure. Oh, the ice will, uh,
volatize will evaporate, will out gas. That's a good one. Uh,
give the thing a little nudge. So predicting it is, is,
uh, difficult to predict it within with the accuracy enough to evacuate cities,
for example, when people have thought deeply about this. And so, uh,
that's why we want to find them all and get ready to give it a name.
Yeah, it sounds like the nudge, the deflection is the,
is the way to go and a good hockey, uh, referenced there. The old deflection,
uh, we have a question from our, um.
Yeah,
the defenseman just puts a stick near it and it goes over the goalies shoulder.
Um, so we have a hard enough time tracking them right now. Like you said,
90%, there's still 10%. We have all this incredible technology telescopes,
et cetera. And now imagine going back to our poor friends,
the dinosaurs who didn't have that ability, that for warning, uh,
and we know about that particular existential, uh,
event for them. Uh, we have a question from somebody in the, what if community,
uh, Karthik Narayan asks, what if an asteroid,
the size of one that killed the dinosaurs came close to earth
didn't necessarily hit us,
but God let's say within our orbit close enough to affect the moon or us,
is there danger there as well?
Well, there's a saying in alliterated saying Mrs is good as a mile
and mile may not be a reference accessible to many Canadian listeners anymore,
but it's, you know, a kilometer and a half that if it misses,
it misses in general, but if it hits it's really bad. So,
uh, on my podcast science rules, we had, uh,
uh, jock Jacquelyn, um,
the woman who did the analysis on the crater in off chicks, a loop,
what is now Chick-fil-A Mexico. And the thing came in so fast.
How fast was it?
It is supposed that it made the atmosphere into a plasma to
assist, to say the atmosphere had got so hot there locally,
uh, that, uh,
the electrons dissociate from their atoms and the air became
opaque. Wow.
It became so hot that it wasn't transparent to sunlight anymore for, you know,
a few seconds. And then, uh,
the wind from it got to what is now France in a few hours.
In other words, the impact was so big. And so, uh,
catastrophic that it affected, uh, the world.
And this is where geologists, you know, when I was in school,
when I was in elementary school, primary school,
nobody really knew what happened to the ancient dinosaurs.
But now everybody's confident in this, that this was the reason,
the cone of the injected material,
the ejector was bigger than the diameter of the earth.
Wow. What, yeah. And then, um,
this material that we all love so much Iridium,
atomic number 77.
So over there Tomic number 77 is all over the
earth because of this impact.
And so if it were to hit that's what happens if it were to miss?
I mean, not much what happened? You presume if I understand her question,
uh, the thing is 30 kilometers across, you know, uh, 20, 20 miles across.
And that's huge, but compared to the earth, it's not that big. I mean,
it's not big at all.
I would just go streaking by what didn't do anything
to the gravity of the moon or anything like that. So I was just pondering.
I'm just thinking out loud. I don't think it's big enough. You know,
we had an earthquake what, six years ago that gave the earth access a nudge.
So I'd have to really, it would, I think it's a clear example of it,
but there's no question. Absolutely. It depends. Yeah.
It depends how big the asteroid is,
how fast it literally is going and then how close it came.
But I would imagine it would be measurable, but not sensible.
In other words,
we have instruments that would measure the gravity deflected deflection due to
its gravity and motion, but a humankind,
a person couldn't feel it I'm imagining.
Well, we're going to we're first of all, this is great stuff. Uh,
we're going to continue with bill Nye to talk about what if we blew up an
asteroid and everything else.
And also talk about a few other cosmological
scenarios, but, uh, bill there's another podcast.
I want to say a better podcast.
Another podcast that people might be interested in might be better, uh,
called science rules with a guy named bill night. Tell us about that.
Uh, so it's a, it's a podcast I do, uh, in two versions.
Uh, every week we have somebody on, um,
who was an expert in his or her field talking about something cool. We had,
um, the gala talking about the asteroid impact,
this thing when you're under pressure, uh, uh, uh,
Jackleen anyway, talking about the asteroid impact we had, uh,
uh, expert on psychopathy. Wow, you're a psychopath.
She pronounces psychopathy. We have, uh,
we have, uh, every, uh,
every two weeks we do a Corona virus edition where we're talking about what's
happening with this pandemic and, uh,
how serious it is and the U S you know, and I, you guys, uh,
as Canadians, I presume you're like everybody else, my colleagues,
I have friends in Denmark and in Japan, they're just shaking their heads.
Like, what are you guys doing?
And this goes back to the beginning of the U S where just these
systems,
these legal systems were in place that just have real limitations that we're
going to have to overcome in the next election.
God speed. Yes. Go ahead and speed with that.
Okay. Great bill. Thanks very much for joining us on the video podcast.
We really appreciate it.
Thank you for promoting my podcast. Be safe out there.
You all the dangerous world for us right now. We'll do. Thanks Belle.
Wow.
So bill Nye, a guy who knows a lot,
also a guy who probably never stops learning doesn't sound like it doesn't know.
And I think you're a guy who likes to never stop learning. Am I right?
Not to the same level of absorption. Let's say as a guy like bill Nye,
the science guy, but yes, I love to learn,
love to continue to learn just like we do every week on the show. Well.
Now is the time to continue your studies or your learning because you know,
with COVID-19, we're all at home, we got,
most of us have a little bit of extra time to learn. Well,
why don't you become more informed, creative, inspired, relaxed,
all with the great courses.
Plus we're really big fans of this aren't we we're sure.
So I was at home the other day and this sounds made up, but it isn't, I'm going,
uh, I'm setting up my smart TV cause I just moved.
So I'm going through the apps available on my smart TV. There's our old friend,
great courses, plus.com.
I'm thinking maybe I could jump in and get prepared for the bill Nye episode.
Whoo moon rocks. There's a whole episode on moon rocks from the Apollo mission.
Uh, this, uh, professor Bob Hazen is talking about this in his words,
the scientific Bonanza that that created 50 years ago when they just came home
with a few rocks from the moon, you'd think, well, that's kind of what is it?
A paperweight? No, they've been actually gleaning tons of scientific info.
And then all of a sudden, we're talking to bill Nye earlier,
and he's talking about moon rocks and how they've actually helped us understand
what the age of our planet continents here, uh, you know,
minerals and elements in the earth. Like it's incredible.
The amount of knowledge we've been able to glean from moon rocks and incredible
the amount of knowledge I was able to glean from a great courses plus.com
episode that I was getting ready for this.
Well, let me tell you the great courses, plus has not only that,
but thousands of lectures on almost any topic imaginable from the history of
Egypt to the study of DNA and new courses are added all the time.
There's someone for everyone, not just moon rock lovers like yourself,
plus every course is presented. Like you say,
by subject matter experts from top universities and institutions, it's,
in-depth reliable fact-based information and you can watch or listen from your
phone or your TV with the great courses plus app at any time from
anywhere in the world. So make the most of your time,
keep learning with the great courses.
Plus right now they're offering fans of this show,
an amazing deal and entire month of access for free this limited time
offer won't last. So sign up today to get started, go to the great courses
plus.com/what if don't wait,
go to the great courses plus.com/ [inaudible].
I think he meant to say the great courses plus.com/ would've.
So I think exactly what I said. So let's go there and get your free month.
So perhaps not surprisingly.
Well maybe it was surprising to people listening or watching,
but if you blow up a massive asteroid,
there is that sort of other piece of the puzzle, which is, I don't know,
the trillion pieces of that puzzle that are going to turn into many sort of
media rights. And all of a sudden, it's not raining men, it's raining,
it's still there's maybe the disaster spread out and it's not as
existential in terms of the impact, but you still gonna have massive damage.
Yeah. And I don't know if it's not going to be as existential. I mean,
bill said it himself, that it could be even worse. You know,
don't know what the number would be a million meteors crashing into earth.
Like that would be devastation on all corners of the planet rather than just
concentrated one area.
One thing I didn't know about asteroids is that they're not necessarily one
large rock. Yes,
they are a cluster of much a deal.
Breathe or whatever, or, but I mean a rubble, I think the word he used,
but it's interesting because really, okay. First of all,
deflection is the only scenario really at the end of the day,
it's rerouting something with whether it's lasers,
whether it's some sort of exp whatever it is, it's not going to be blow it up.
It has to be push it off course away from the earth. That's pretty much it.
And again that the lead-up you'd need again, you'd have to know what's coming.
And as he talked about, we know where a lot of them are coming. 90%.
We know where 90% of them are.
Did that, did that reassure you, Peter? That there's 10% that we don't know? Ah,
no. I was surprised by,
I was waiting to hear we know 98.9 and there's
maybe a couple of surprises, 10%. It's a big window.
You said it was a big window,
but in just envisioning how large space is like,
I don't blame anybody for missing, missing 10% of the restaurants on the way.
Not throwing shade at the people man in the telescope.
And the millennium Falcon going through, uh, a meteor field.
Can you count all those things?
No. And I mean, and again,
close to that's that incredible piloting skill of Han solo, but no, I mean,
it is interesting that really, this is Sarah that's been talked about.
We talked about it off the top with movies and whatever,
and really it's not feasible because the question marks the downsides,
the risk versus the reward factor too high. It seems like,
uh, the, you know, the more you talk about these scenarios,
which get entertained, whether it's through Spotify or whatever else it is,
you realize that yeah, you want to be prepared,
but you can only be prepared for so much. And in this case,
this doesn't seem like going up there with a nuclear bomb and blowing up an
asteroid is even on the table. No.
Not at all. Well, if you enjoyed our chat with bill Nye, the science guy,
and want to hear more with him, well, join us in the extended audio version.
Just click on the link in the description below,
and we'll have more with bill Nye, the science guy he'll join us.
And we'll talk more about exploding nuclear bombs in space and possible
extinction level event.
Yes. The scenarios,
the ideas about what to do with an asteroid are just fantastic.
Make your spacecraft so big.
How big would it be that it's gravity would,
could be used to tug the asteroid,
a gravity tug ship tug the asteroid off of course, a little bit.
Then you mentioned setting off a nuclear weapon in the hopes that the
expanding gases or atoms would give the asteroid a nudge
or give it,
set it off so that the material of the asteroid itself would have momentum
to give the asteroid a nudge.
Lots more interesting stuff with bill Nye in the extended audio version.
We'll see you next time on what if discussed.